just thank you organizers for inviting
me to present our work here now I will
help resend ongoing work with Ellie was
premature Institute that builds up on
our previous work in context reality
with danya seen w3 D'Antoni loveria so
at the very beginning I will somehow
review our formalism for context oddity
and then move on to the composition bit
of the talk so the context valatie
scenario the way that we visualize the
setup of the experiments or to say is we
have a system where we can perform
measurements and obtain outcomes so that
is the setup that you have to keep in
mind throughout the whole talk of course
if I just stop here and this is all I
give you you will be a bit disappointed
because this is somehow trivially boring
it's not like yesterday when we had this
example of the particle in the box that
was the simplistic that we could have
and still it was interesting this is
somehow trivial so what we do to make it
more interesting is to identify
different outcomes of different
measurements so that's the set that you
must have in mind and what do I mean by
this that's supposed and let me dig the
situation in this way that we have two
different measurements so each of this
ellipsis is a measurement and each of
them has three outcomes and the outcomes
are to be good by this dot there it
might happen that we perform these
measurements on our system and we check
or we actually see that for all the
possible preparations of the system
these two outcomes they're always happen
with the same probability and if that's
the case then we will identify those two
outcomes or say that those two outcomes
correspond to actually the same event
and then we will have a situation like
this so now we will have two different
measurements but some of their outcomes
have been identified this might seem
somehow a little bit like impulse we
know physical grounds but this is
actually something there arises
naturally with in quantum theory even
though quantum theory is not what we
want to assume throughout the talk for
instance in quantum theory actually a
measurement is the realization of the
identity so it's basically a sum of
positive operators that give you the
identity and if it happens that the
operator the resource which associated
to this outcome here is the same word
that you associate to the other outcome
then you always obtain the same
probability regardless of which is the
density matrix of the system that you
are performing your measurements on so
basically that's why we have in mind
when we say well two different events
can be identified as being the same one
so our formulation for contacts qaulity
basically takes as a starting point the
set of measurements that you can perform
on your system and D identifications
among the different outcomes of the
measurements and a very useful way to
depict such a situation is via hyper
graph so a context y UT scenario
basically is given by a hypergraph where
the vertices are the possible
measurement outcomes that you can obtain
in the experiment and the hyper edges
contain all the outcomes for each of the
measurements and from here on we will
assume that the measurements are
complete so every time you perform a
measurement one of the outcomes of that
measurement must occur now given that we
have this situation here so this context
authority scenario the object that we're
interested in studying our conditional
probability distributions that is the
assignment of values between 0 1 to each
of the vertices such that that value
represents the probability that such an
outcome occurs whenever the measurement
is performed for instance
this one here is a possible assignment
of probabilities to this particular
hyper graph that I depicted and the
threat of all the possible probabilistic
models that satisfy this normalization
constraints because we would like the
probabilities to sum up to D to one for
each of the hyper edges is what we call
the set of General probabilistic models
and they actually form a polytope but
now this is like a very general way of
looking at the situation so in practice
we have now in the labs classical
systems or quantum systems so we would
like to see what happens if we further
assume that the nature of the system
that we are acting on is either
classical quantum so in the case where
it's classical then the possible
probabilities that may arise are those
that are compatible with the local
hidden variable model so to say or a no
contextual hidden variable model so
basically are those where the
probabilities are just a linear
combination of deterministic models on
the hypergraph for instance this this
one here is actually a deterministic
model and when that happens then the
possible probabilistic models that may
arise in the experiment is just a subset
of all the possible ones that we would
have otherwise but now if we want to
assume that the system has a quantum
system and the way perform measurements
in it what actually the way that we
model is is well an assignment of
probabilities will have a quantum nature
of quantum realization if there exists a
Hilbert space and a state or the system
and measurement projectors for each of
the outcomes such that the probabilities
are recovered we are born rule and of
course since we are working with
complete measurements we would like
those projectors to sum up to the
identity for each of the hyper edges
when we do so we recover asset that can
be slightly larger than the classical
set for certain context variety
scenarios and it's actually the fact
that there exists from the quality
scenarios from
there are quantum models that have no
classical realization what we refer to
as context valatie so the fact that
there is that got there is what Cohen
spec realized some years ago in the
sixties and that's what we didn't know
about context quality so so far so good
so this is a way to describe a situation
where we have a system we perform
measurements obtained outcomes and we
want to study the statistics of those
headphones now the way the question that
we ask is what happens if we have two
different such situations what happens
if we have for instance Alice and Bob
and each of them has their own systems
there are measurement sets there on
outcomes their own identifications and
we want to try to understand those two
separate systems as just being one so
how starting from the two individual
hypergraphs can we construct a hyper
graph that represents the situation that
joint situation and of course there are
many different ways that want to think
of you know composing two different
hypergraphs but one of the properties
that we would like for the new
hypergraph to have is that this set of
probabilistic models allowed on this
joint hypergraph satisfies the no
signaling principle that is that when we
take the marginal over whatever outcomes
Bob obtains in his share of the state
that the marginal condition of already
distribution for Alice does not depend
on his choice of measurement so that's
the property that we would like this new
hypergraph to have and just don't be
perhaps misled by this but this is just
an example that I draw where Alison both
have two diatomic measurements each but
what I'm saying holds for any arbitrary
conduct radisson Aereo for the parties
and actually we were not the first ones
to ask for this question and it was
answered quite nicely in a different
context by fully and Randall
and they defined their fully rendered
product of hypergraphs that actually
answers this question so whenever we
want to define a new hyper graph that
tells you what is the way to compose
those two subsystems then basically you
take the fully rendered product and you
obtain what we want it to begin with so
that's a very wonderful thing and for
instance here is this very complicated
hyper graph is the fully rounded product
of those two very simple ones no that is
not just a Cartesian product which is
given by this blue sets but it has
something else in there so now even
though this is really nice now one can
be a bit ambitious and say well this is
for assistance what happens if we have
more parties involved in the experiments
so what happens if we have three
different contexts riety scenarios and
we want to combine them to form just one
and there we ran into problems because
the fully rendered product is not
associative so it depends on where you
put the bracket what is the hyper graph
that you obtain in the end so the now
possible question would be how can we
generalize to multipartite situations
such a fully rendered product in a way
that the resultant hyper graph as i
mentioned before allows only for no
signaling probabilistic models and even
though one might think that such a
constraint is a you know a very strong
one it gives rise to more than one
possibility actually we found a
hierarchy of products for this hyper
graph that all of them give rises to
different join her progress however they
all have the same set of no signal in
probabilistic models allowed so here I
just I'm of course I cannot comment of
all the possible ways but I highlighted
three so basically the minimum and the
maximum products which are the two
extremes he's hired
product and then one that we've got used
to referring to you as a common product
which is the one that might be a little
bit more natural for operational
purposes I unfortunately don't have the
time to go in detail what it each of
these products is but the main idea
behind it is that for this minimum
product so all of them have the same set
of vertices which is the cartesian
product of the vertex set they do differ
on the hyper edges so for instance here
the hyper edges of the minimal products
that is just the union of all the
possible ways of taking a by partition
between one party and rest and the rest
of the parties you just take the
cartesian product of the edge set and
then fully randall with the remaining
party in here you should take the union
of all the possible ways of taking
bracketing in the fully Randall
expression and well for maximal product
it's a little bit more comforted yet but
it relies on the notion or the
definition of what a measurement
protocol is operationally between all
the parties so if any of you is
interested in that I can comment on it
in the coffee break or later so as a
mathematician one could say well all of
these are equally valid answers because
they all give rise to a joint
representation of the scenario that you
know have the properties that we want
but then perhaps a physicist could be a
bit disappointed because you could have
in the back of your mind well I would
like to relieve the Nature has one
possible way of combining systems and
not that there are many ways and you
know it just flips a coin and depending
on each mode it decides which way to
compose that time so one could say well
how about we device experiment and we
compute the statistics and from this
addictive of experiments see like if we
have a quantum system see which are the
correlation that we obtain and then we
see if they can belong to each of these
join hybrid joint hypergraphs there then
is when we run into problems
because actually classical and quantum
probabilistic models are observational
equivalent that is the set of classical
and quantum correlations that you can
obtain for all these different products
are the same so if you want to rely on
an experiment or quantum experiment or
classical experiment to tell one from
the other you will never succeed so one
possible question is whether this is
like some fundamental property of nature
and that we could learn something from
it or if it's just coincidence that it
just happened that the family or the
hierarchy of products that we found out
have this particular property but we
still don't really have any intuition
about this and we don't know which which
of those cases should actually be
happening but what we try it is like
well how about we pro these different
products from a different perspective
like other prova listing models which
are not this particular one that have
this curious property and that's how we
moved on to almost quantum models that
actually Marcus was mentioning almost
quantum correlations is a stove before
so within this formalism almost 12
models are defined as follows so it has
a very similar definition than the
quantum one but here we don't demand
that the projector sum up to the
identity so basically the probability is
that they recover shoots them up to the
identity however the projectors can be
submerged so this trivially gives has
quantum correlations as a special case
and here actually we were able to find
at least one difference so there exists
context loyalty scenarios for a
tripartite case when the minimum product
the minimal product gives a different
set of correlations that the common
product
and that actually we found it for the
simplest example that you can get which
is two diatonic measurements for party
and the way that we signal this
difference between the two sexes is by
testing maximum violations of the linear
qualities the one that I we found it
actually this behavior for different
inequalities that the one that I wanted
to present here is get your neighbors
input where we see that for almost
quantum models in the common product
scenario we obtain a maximum value of
one however we can go beyond that value
for almost quantum models in the mineral
products scenario so this we obviously
observed this behavior for different
Bell inequalities this is a particular
one the reason why I chose this one two
percent in this talk is because it's
clear from this inequality that almost
quantum models in the minimum product
scenario violate the local authority
principle so now why could argue that
well since local authorities principle
what would happen if now we impose the
principal at hawk and do exactly the
same like maximizing violation of value
inequalities imposing this principle to
begin with and surprisingly when we do
that all the gaps disappear so not just
for this particular inequality for which
it would be trivially the case since
this is a local orthogonal itta
constraint to begin with but for other
very inequalities that are not in local
authority form imposing local atonality
from the outside reduces the gap and
yeah i have to also say that for all the
possible inequalities that we sampled
from when we were doing this research we
were not able to be point to pinpoint
any difference between the common
product scenarios and maximal product
scenarios so
a working conjecture is that perhaps
those two scenarios even though they
have different set of hybrids they
actually give rise to equivalent
constraints as far as almost quantum
correlations are concerned so as well it
would be up to four up to you to decide
but this could be like a mathematical
curiosity or yet another way you're on a
proposal to compose systems but let me
introduce you briefly to the notion of a
completion scenario so a completion
scenario basically starts from
hypergraph so let's take this one as an
example and that's the following for
instance in this case we can have an
assignment for that remember to set the
appt want that of value P and because of
the normalization of the probabilities
that implies that this vertex down here
has a value of 1 minus P so for all
practical purposes p this the one the
green one up here and agreement down
here sum up to 1 so they do behave as if
they belonged to a measurement to begin
with so if we did that and we included
this dashed hyperedge there then the set
of possible general probabilistic models
here wouldn't change so this dashed
highbridge here is what we call a
virtual edge and actually the way that
you construct the completion scenario
from a certain context rarity scenario
is by including india set all the
possible virtual edges and of course by
the finish in the set of probably stick
models allowed in those two hyper hyper
graph is the same they coincide example
the presence of those too hyper edges of
the far right for speed equal one minus
P well yeah in this particular one yeah
yes well exactly so here you have to if
you want to include all the possible
virtual edges you will have to do all
the oh the other yes exactly this is I
mean this one was a nice example because
it gives you the idea of what a virtual
edge is it's perhaps a trivial scenario
because it that meets only one possible
probabilistic model but I'd rather
present something that gives a clear
idea for the virtual edge is regardless
of where there is an interesting
scenario or not yeah yeah so yeah so the
curious thing here is that classical and
quantum rolls also have the property so
if you have a classical and quantum
assignments in the original hyper graph
then they would also be valid at certain
assignments in the completion hypergraph
so one could think out and sorry and
another property is that the completion
when you have a product hypergraph
that's not depend on the choice of
product so you take this family of
different products that we found you
take the one that you like the most you
use that one to compute the joint
scenario and then when you complete it
you obtain the same thing that you would
have if you have chosen any other
product so one possibility or one
proposal would be to say well perhaps a
joint scenario would actually be the
completion of all this possible products
given that that thing is invariant I
don't know if there is any physical
motivation to do such a thing but given
that we don't even have motivations for
the other products to begin with them
this is yet another proposal
sorry yeah lister god mode any flash
doctors ah yes so yeah so basically what
i tried to are you in this past 15-20
minutes is that within this hybrid
Rephaim work for context quality there
is no a unique way to compose the
systems when you want to work with
multipartite experiments and however
from the different ways that we study it
to try to compose the systems general
models classical models and quantum
models have give no difference so
they're all operationally equivalent
almost quantum models on the other hand
do not have a property so if nature was
almost quantum then perhaps you could
device an experiment to see which is the
way that nurtured prefers to compose
systems however if actually the local
orthogonal principle holds and we reduce
we are left with almost quantum models
that respect this principle then we
still wouldn't have a test because the
bell inequalities that we found so far
the witness gaps don't witness those
caps anymore but now the fact that all
the inequalities that we've started have
this property doesn't mean that that's
actually what happens in general so
there could still be the case that there
are gaps that local earth of analogy
might not might not eliminate so one
possible thing to do is to try to study
other multipartite scenarios other Bell
inequalities and try to see if we find a
contra example to the fact that ello
removes the gaps and also like I said
everything that I've been saying
corresponds to a gap between the minimum
and common product but we still haven't
been able to witness any gaps between
comb and Max so our also completion if
we include as a possible way to combine
systems so it would be actually
nice to see if there is a way to tell
them apart from the point of view of
interesting probabilistic models or not
and last but not least one of the things
that motivates me the most is try to
find an intuition or a reason why we
should settle for one product and not
for another or try to understand how
like how to understand nature and see
which is the way that we should compose
these systems to you know reveal its
behavior and with that thank you very
much for your attention
[Applause]
so she take the Iran valid product and
unit so if you take the initial product
so can you run that and you add the
completion so you get a new product
which is associated I guess so but you
would take the completion mm-hmm so
maybe maybe it means that this is this
one which is the good product oh yeah I
see your point okay yeah like
I yeah that's that's true I don't know I
don't really have any physical intuition
of why for instance that would be the
sensible thing to do on not to take the
common product for instance that's well
what I what I mean by us originally
equivalents that they admit the same
sets of probabilistic models like what
if you have a quantum assignment here
and you translate it to this other to
the other scenario then that's also a
valid quantum assignment there so you
would not have like a quantum assignment
or one scenario that is not valid on
another scenario like what you had with
you almost want to models yeah it's like
things magically normalized and
satisfiable
[Applause]